عبد العظيم لدينا تحديث بحسب معلومات تشير
بعد فرد 77% من الاصوات تشير الى تقدم
الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان بخمسين فاصل سبعه
بالمئه مقابل
43.1% لكمال كريستار اوغلو ماذا تعني هذه
الارقام تعني ان الارجح ان الامور ستذهب
باتجاه انتخابات جوله ثانيه من
الانتخابات وهذا واضح جدا من سير العمليه
الانتخابيه ومن النتائج
كمال
يصعد قليلا اردوغان ينزل قليلا لكنه قارب
الى نسبه الخمسين بالمئه
والمفاجاه هي سنان اوغان حصل على نسبه
اصوات عاليه جدا اخذ فاصله مليونين مصوت
صوته لسيدان اوغان لكن المعارضه الان
تتحدث عن
هناك محاوله من الاعلام المسيطر عليه
الحكومه والتحالف الحاكم والتحكم بعمليه
نشر
الاصوات التي تنشر من خلال وكاله الاناضول
من خلال وسائل الاعلام التركيه لماذا
المعارضه تقول ان التحالف الحاكم تعمد فرز
اصوات
المدن التي هو مسيطر فيها والتي تصوت
العداله والتنميه مثلا
الاناضول محافظات الاناضول والبحر الاسود
تم فرز في بعض المناطق فرز 90% من هذه
البلدات والمدن وبعضها 80% في حين
المدن التي هي تقليديا مؤيده
حزب الشعب الجمهوري والتحالف الشعب لم يصل
للتصويت فيها في بعضها وصل الى 40 لا زال
عند اربعين وبعضها عند 50 وعند 60% اذا
اردنا ان نعطي الضوء اكثر على هذه الاصوات
هناك
اكبر خمس مدن في تركيا هي
اسطنبول
ازمير بورصه انطاليا هذه المدن حتى الان
في اسطنبول وهي اسطنبول الحاسمه ومؤثره
جدا جدا حتى الان تم فرز 62% النسب
متقاربه مع تقدم طفيف بفارق درجتين لكم
48% 46 نزلت نسبه اردوغان في في هذه في
اخر عمليه
نشر للاصوات نزلت درجتين
اما في انقره اردوغان متقدم بشكل
ايضا بفارق درجتين اي ان النسب متقاربه
جدا في هاتين اكبر مديتين هناك 11 مليون
صوت في
اسطنبول وهناك اكثر من ثلاثه ملايين في
انقره في ازمير وهي ايضا مؤثره جدا هناك
ايضا اكثر من ثلاث ملايين صوت في ازمير تم
فرز 67% الفارق شاسع 61% لصالح اردوغان
و32 لصالح
كمالك لصالح اردوغان وبورصه التقدم ايضا
فيها واضح لرجب طيب اردوغان بيفارق تقريبا